I've been sitting here for the last
three minutes trying to think of a
decent cold-open and all I'm coming up
with is quotes from Shakespeare and
whatnot about dreams and they all just
feel really lame so let's move on so
news has broken about a Netflix
adaptation of Neil Gaiman's monumental
comic-book work The Sandman if you
aren't familiar with the Sandman first
of all turn this video off and go read
The Sandman it's 50 issues it's 10
volumes not counting overture which is
the new one which is fine but not
required
but like just I don't care how long it's
gonna take you go do that just do that
cuz you're missing out on a lot so but
if on the off chance that yeah I don't
know maybe you have a life or something
I don't huh that if you haven't read or
aren't familiar with or only kind of
know Sandman
it was a fifty issue series that dealt
with primarily basically the Lord of
Dreams the character intermittently
called dream or Morpheus so the titular
Sandman who ruled over the dream realm
which not only had to do with what
people imagine when they're asleep but
also it's basically the repository of
stories so if you if you've been out
around my channel before you may have
caught a wind of me saying something
along the lines of I like stories about
stories the point at which I realized
that about myself was while reading
Sandman so there you kind of go so this
is a
[Music]
long sprawling frequently nonlinear
frequently diverging story to try and
adapt that's kind of been the
fundamental problem with previous
attempts to try and adapt this now I say
try because this has been optioned a
couple of times and has started to move
forward at various points as a film it's
never gotten further than the scripting
stage couple years ago Joseph
gordon-levitt was working on it was
gonna direct it prior to that there was
there was a script by I can't remember
the the authors the screenwriters name
now and then you know prior like few
years prior to that there was another
script that was being optioned but it's
never gotten very far along
I suspect largely because of the nature
of the narrative so like there are
chunks of Sandman that actually kind of
have a steady progression and sort of
straightforward story like if I I read
it in train so I think about in terms of
volume so like the first volume preloads
in knock terms relatively
straightforward the second volume
dollhouse not at all and then you know
it's not until the volume for that you
kind of get a straightforward story
again with seasons amidst and then it's
a bit all over the place again and then
volume 9 you get the kindly ones which
is more or less straightforward and then
it wraps up on a very strange note as
far as these sorts of things go but I
mean by that point it more than earned
the way that it ended but it's the
things that you would have to do to
Sandman to make it work on film more
than likely would make it unrecognizable
as Sandman Sandman while it is a comic
book it is a visual story is an
incredibly literate piece of work it it
is making commentary on stories and that
is and it's doing so in a way that works
on the page does not necessarily
translate not only just works on the
page but works on the page in a way that
was intended to be digested
1:24 however many page issue at a time
over months and years not to be hurled
at you in two hours so they'd like I
said adaptations have always had been
hiccups in this thing so I have no doubt
that the success of Good Omens is a big
part of why Netflix jumped on this and
decided to to option it up now first
thing to point out this point in the
process you know getting optioned
initial script work being done the
properties gotten this far before so
until I actually hear that they are they
have begun shooting a pilot I'm still
gonna take this with a grain of salt
that it actually happens because this
thing is such a serious thing you know
serious odd piece of work to try and
adapt to film or television that said
television is a better fit than film
because television because of the
isolation of individual episodes and
then even within that individual seasons
gives you the opportunity to tackle it
in a way similar to how it was done in
the comic book and I think I've actually
said before I actually did a video a
while back with my pitch for how to
actually do it as a movie series I still
stand by those ideas but just by its
nature television is a better fit and I
think I've mentioned that somewhere
along the line might have been on a live
stream that what I would love to see
them do I don't presume there's gonna
happen but what I would love to see them
do is with each season of the show
completely change the visual stylings
like have a season that's in black and
white have a season that's animated have
a because if you read the book they they
would change artists as they went along
so different volumes have completely
different art styles initially by
necessity because the original artist
sam keith was kind of clashing with
Gaiman in terms of what they were
getting for so he left because the
partnership wasn't quite working out but
then it actually kind of became a
function of the story that
as each you story-arc began we got a
different art style I'd love to see the
show do that but I'm getting ahead of
myself on this so when I initially heard
this news I should got very very very
nervous after at first getting excited
because it said Neil Gaiman was actually
going to be working on the show he
wasn't just going you know good luck you
know you work on that which is basically
what he done every time it had been
optioned as a movie he'd never worked in
the scripts when that had gone on but
this time he was going to at least be
more involved than he had in any of the
other previous attempts to adapt it but
then I got nervous because there was
another name I saw which was David Goyer
now David Goyer he is a screenwriter and
a producer of film and television best
known for his work at this point on the
blade franchise and the first two Nolan
Batman films uh it's debatable how much
of his work actually ended up on the
screen in the Dark Knight but he
absolutely wrote the the primary draft
for Batman Begins he also worked on
things like Batman V Superman Man of
Steel and it's it's not just like it's
not like I have a grudge against those
things here's my opinion of David Goyer
as a writer at this point unless you
pair him with the director who really
knows what they're doing and what they
plan to do and has a clear vision that
works for the story being told his
scripts aren't that good he the best
work ever made out of something he wrote
was always done by screenwriters who had
really unique vision although I suppose
in light of Batman V Superman that's
also true of one of the worst films made
out something hero but you know that's a
whole other discussion talking about
what went wrong with that film but if
you look at things like the blade movies
Stephen Norrington and the first one and
then general del Toro well the second
one had really clear visions of how they
were gonna execute this and they gave it
their own spin the third blade film that
David Goyer actually directed is bland
and dull
and horrible and then you've got stuff
like the Batman Begins on The Dark
Knight
Christopher Nolan really a clear idea of
what he wanted to do so David Gore your
scripts are they're just kind of a I
don't want to go so far as to say a
blank slate but they completely depend
on the director now like a bad director
can ruin a good even a good script but
if you have a good script that puts you
in a much better position and basically
the movies he's been involved in and
same with the TV shows for that matter
are only good when in the hands of
people you know working past the writing
stage you know taking it up after him
who are really good at what they do but
if you ever see something that he was
involved in that didn't turn out good
you don't go that's a shame because the
script was real good so and plus there's
other things he said at various points
about his opinions of certain things and
characters in relation to various things
that it's kind of tainted my opinion of
the man I don't want to get into detail
on that because it's it's not like with
Gareth Roberts
that I had to tackle last month it's
nothing of that scale just like oh dude
come on
but anyways Neil Gaiman has clarified
that while David s Goyer is involved he
is producing he's not working on the
scripts at the very least not the
initial scripts which is good because
David Gore there's a producer I am much
more okay with because he's actually
produced some very interesting stuff and
has a tendency to sort of get involved
in lend his name to things that maybe
wouldn't get made without his name being
attached things like assassination
assassination nation man that title is
hard to say or there was another off the
time I had that bad now I've lost but
like these odd little films that you
probably wouldn't even gotten made if he
hadn't backed them so him as a producer
I'm much more comfortable with than him
as a writer
apparently the showrunner is gonna be a
guy by the name of Allan Heinberg who I
don't really know
he worked on the script for Wonder Woman
and prior to that a whole bunch of TV
which means he's you know he's got a
general foundation and background I
think the only thing that that I saw in
his resume that I probably would have
seen he wrote some episodes of Sex in
the City which I haven't revisited that
show and ages but say what you will
about the show scripts are usually
pretty well written but I don't know
enough about him to either be made
nervous or feel good about it now Gaiman
has said he is going to help write the
pilot at the very least I would be
surprised if he sticks around to do a
lot of active writing past that he has
been very clear that he's not gonna show
run again the way he did for Good Omens
he doesn't want to do that kind of time
commitment
um which you know that fair enough
the other thing that he said that
actually sort of feeds into when I kind
of got ahead of myself talking about
different seasons being in the different
styles he said that this first season is
going to be 11 episodes and basically be
pre ludes and nocturnes which is the
first collected volume of Sandman so if
they approach this and tackle this as
basically a volume per season
that might work I think they're still
gonna have to like tweak it because
there are some of those volumes that
like involve Morpheus so little and
really are gonna depend on the audience
being invested in characters that are
not the guy who theoretically the thing
is about so like like volumes like a
dollhouse is kind of a bit divisive
among fans partly for that reason and
that's like an early I think that's the
second or maybe that's the third is a
brief lives is the second I can't
remember but things you know go in funky
directions fairly early on to the point
that I think probably doing a volume per
season like doing that straight as
you're playing probably not going to
work your
I'm gonna have to take some of those
more divergent or whimsical volumes and
like kind of integrate those into some
of the more solid narrative seasons like
you can have things going on in a
dollhouse run like in parallel as a be
plot to something like seasons of mist
I'm just thinking about off the top my
head I'm not actually entirely sure that
that's clocks but something along those
lines so I think depending on how this
turns out we could potentially get I'm
gonna go with a guess of seven solid two
great seasons of television out of this
I love Sandman and I would love to see
it adapted well I'm very nervous about
it as I would be about anything that is
not only something that I think is
really good but it is really
particularly tailored to the medium it
was originally told in which I do think
Sandman absolutely is that doesn't make
it unadaptable it just means you have to
go about adapting it incredibly
carefully because the things you need to
alter because they were designed to work
in a completely other medium you have to
be sure don't cause it to lose the sense
of what it is or if you make the choice
to keep those things suddenly you have
something that doesn't necessarily work
in the medium you're now working and
because you've kept all these elements
that were designed to work elsewhere and
I don't know what will happen but I'm
gonna be keeping an eye on this I'm
gonna be curious about casting I really
hope that they go unknown for for Dream
especially they probably won't like
they'll probably need you know some
sizable name I would like I would cast
little known or unknown for dream I
would get somebody recognizable for say
death or delirium or some of the other
or you know the other endless really
that's Morpheus as siblings you know
your
other recurring characters get get some
known folks but like dream himself yeah
I say go unknown on that but I don't
expect them to do that we'll see what we
get
Sandman the series on Netflix speaky is
someone often really skeptical who
zeroes in on the way things can go wrong
the information we have so far doesn't
give me too much reason to worry a
little not a lot which is pretty much my
equivalent of hey that could be really
good so if you're new to this channel
that's that's me kind of climbing
youtube my own personal scale of
enthusiasm and optimism which is skewed
so we'll wrap it up there folks
Sandman on Netflix what do you think
about this news has something have new
details leaked between when I shot this
and when the video went up and you're
wondering why didn't bring that up
whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it bunch of stuff to do down
there as well
there's the patreon which is a huge help
there's the like button which is also
big help you folks been hitting it
lately and I appreciate it you can
subscribe you can check out links below
for merch my p.o box etc or you could
just do something else and not click on
any of it
I mean I'd appreciate it if you would
but I'm not gonna tell you what to do
you're the council I just run the
meetings so until next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]